life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
these are the unalienable rights endowed
by our creator and set forth in the
Declaration of Independence
which of course was written here in this
great
and historic city of Philadelphia just a
few blocks from where we are right now
life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness these these
powerful words are all that any American
or really any human being
could ever hope for
and
these words represent
the
the just and self-evident truths
that our great nation was founded upon
and the Declaration of Independence
Carries On
to explain that when these rights are
reduced or abused by tyranny or evil
it is the duty of the people
to throw off and absolve themselves from
that tyranny
but
there is an implied
an unspoken addendum to this document
yes
there is an important part of the
Declaration of Independence that is
actually left unsaid
but what is unsaid is an idea that
anyone who understands history and
anyone that understands human nature
will know that there is
an elevated calling
Beyond those unalienable rights
because you see
in order for one group of sovereign
people to reap the blessings of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
there must be another group
another group who are willing to
sacrifice and forego those sacred rights
that
other group of people
those are our Warriors
those are the men and women of our
military
because when an American citizen raises
their hand and swears the oath of
service
what they are doing
is willingly placing their life their
Liberty and their personal happiness on
the altar of Freedom they are
relinquishing
the blessings bestowed by this great
nation these these Warriors Commit This
somber Act
in order to defend
the higher ideal that is the United
States of America
our military troops volunteer so they
can uphold
this glorious vision of Destiny this
Supreme object of human value
freedom
and for freedom and for Liberty our
military men and women are willing to
sacrifice everything that they have
everything that they have now
and everything that they ever could have
all their hopes all their dreams
all their aspirations
our subordinator subordinated to this
higher cause
these soldiers Sailors Airmen and
Marines
they give their futures
for ours
now
this is exactly what
Travis Manion did
not in some
conceptual or abstract way
no Travis Manion factually decided to
put the lives of his team above his own
and he did it at the moment of truth he
did it in combat
and in combat there's no time
to Think Through Your philosophical
beliefs
there's no internal discussion
about our nation's great Endeavors or
the high aims of our country
no
in combat your values must already be
decided they must already be established
they must be Resolute in your soul
and Travis's values were absolutely
embedded in his character
indelibly
etched into his spirit and his Spirit
would show no fear
would show no hesitation would show no
wavering
there was no fear
as he exposed himself to enemy fire to
rescue his corpsman from the Kill Zone
there was no hesitation as he directed
his Patrol in a counter-attack
there was no wavering when he rescued
another Marine and personally Drew enemy
fire away from the rest of his troops
and with this
unconquerable spirit and this determined
character
on that bloody and violent Battlefield
Travis sacrificed his life for his
friends
now
we need to be thankful
for Travis menu
and for the men and women like him
many of whom you heard about tonight we
need to be thankful because it's Heroes
like Travis
who have given us this gift of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
yes
without question
we should and we must live every day in
a way
that will honor the sacrifices of those
Heroes that is our charge
but there's something
equally important
that Travis and heroes like Travis
they've given all of us
this is a gift that is
just as precious
as the freedom and liberty that we all
hold so dear
and that gift is the example that Travis
sent
the example that he set the life that he
led which so clearly revealed
that a true hero
a true model for mankind is not is not
someone who fights for his own life
not someone who fights for his own
liberty
not someone
who fights for his own pursuit of
happiness
no
the ultimate ideal the ultimate American
the ultimate hero
is one who puts others first
because you see Travis did not serve to
protect his own life
but to defend others he didn't sacrifice
for his own liberty
but for all of ours
he didn't lay down his life for his own
happiness
but so that his friends could one day
find their happiness
that
is the example
that Travis Manny had said
that is the path of righteousness that
he laid down
to be followed
knowing the risks knowing the hazard
knowing the peril
knowing the possible outcome of his
choices and actions could be death
knowing all that
he needed only to ask
if not me
then who
if I do not volunteer who will
if I do not deploy who will if I do not
lead who will if I do not serve who will
if I do not place my life on the altar
of sacrifice for my country
who will
Travis answered that question
and he answered it with complete and
unmitigated resolve
who will go
Travis Manion will go
so
we are here tonight
to remember Travis's story and his
legacy but we must also remember
that while Travis's story is
the idealized representation of what it
means to be a hero
traps is not just a hero
not just a myth
not just a legend
Travis was a man
he was a real man
he was a son
he was a brother
he was a friend he was a teammate
he was a man
who no matter what
no matter what would not let down his
friends
will not let down his Marines
would not let down his country
so
we thank you Travis we thank you
obviously for these sacred gifts that
you have bestowed upon each of us life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
we promise we will relish our freedom
and we will pursue our own manifestation
of happiness
but also
thanks to you Travis we will strive
we will strive to be better
we'll strive to give more we'll strive
to be more we will strive to do more but
not for ourselves
but for others
that is the task you have entrusted us
with
and we will not forget your Solomon
and heroic example
and we will not forget
your words
if not me
then who
thank you Travis
we will do our best
to follow your lead
thank you God Bless America